what's going on everybody and welcome to
a neat video on the
neat algorithm so uh if you're not
familiar with the neat algorithm
it stands for neural evolution of
augmenting topologies
and as the name suggests it's an
evolutionary style algorithm
and the main crux of this is that rather
than like in a traditional neural
network
you've got a predefined you know n
layers size per layer
and what gets tweaked through training
is we're adjusting weights and biases
um whereas with the neat algorithm
what's happening is we're augmenting the
topology so we're actually changing the
model itself
so as it as we're training let's say
this this model what we're actually
doing is we're adding and removing
uh things like nodes and connections uh
we can also change weights and biases
but that's not the main
the main thing with the main idea here
is that we're actually changing the
structure of the neural network so we
tend to start
with a very simple neural network and
then it just kind of grows over time
based on the structure that is most
successful
i.e the evolutionary aspect if you want
to learn more about
how it works i've pulled up a few things
here so
first of all we're going to be using the
neat python library to do this
and on this page where
now i'm kind of lost on this page yes
here we go
we have the selected publications also
if you just google
the neat paper you should find it
and the original paper is actually
pretty short pretty simple i think to
understand
also of note it was published in 2002
so this is kind of prior to major gpu
advances
which also is one of the cool things
about the neat algorithm is that you can
you basically have to it runs on the cpu
rather than a gpu so
anybody can follow along you're kind of
limited at this point by
your cpu power but i will also say
at least through my own tinkering there
has been no problem
that can be can be solved with the neat
algorithm
that is not solved pretty quickly so
you're not going to be training uh for
days or weeks here
this is um not that um
it's just not the same kind of style of
problem is going to be solved by the
neat algorithm
that would otherwise be solved through
what we now know is like
reinforcement learning algorithms that
leverage gpus so
i don't think we'll ever see the neat
algorithm defeating
alphago or writing papers but what it
can do is produce some pretty
interesting results so
anyway what we're going to leverage this
on and oh i also wanted to just say
if you do want to learn more about how
the true inner workings
if you go to this if you basically go to
the neat python page and you can go to
the selected publications
um the the this one uh goes into
quite a bit more detail but there's a
whole bunch of information here so
you can if you want you can get a lot
more information on how things work here
so um anyway i will
close close close and then the
environment that we're going to leverage
this on at least to start
is going to be the open ai environments
purely because they are so
simple to get started and then we're
going to change the environment just so
you have an idea of
when you when you change your
environment what needs to be changed
um in your kind of configuration file
so uh so yeah so that's what we're going
to be uh doing so to get both of those
you're going to do a
pip install gym that gives you
the basic version of openai's gym and
then
pip 3 pip install meet python hopefully
everyone is on python 3 at this point
now for the gym stuff it's gonna vary
depending on
um different operating systems this pip
install gym
should let everyone use at least cart
pull like these things you should be
able to do everything on this page
with a simple pip install gym it's when
you want to use other things so the
other one that we're going to do
is this box 2d walker i'm going to do
that
on ubuntu this is what i needed to
install first before
doing this i fail on something
whatever the replacement for ffm mpeg is
uh i forget what it was but i just
needed to swap it for mpeg and
it worked so anyway it's kind of varied
by your operating system
and you don't even have to ch like if
when i show you how what we do to change
things you
you can apply this to any other
environment or make your own environment
and at the end i will show you
um the thing that i ended up doing which
is kind of cool
so um so yeah so those that's the
information if you have
problems or whatever feel free to post
it below and i'll do my best to help you
but like i said it varies by operating
system and closed ai doesn't really help
anymore
so so um okay
so the first thing i'll do is show you
the cart pull environment so
in this case we're going to use cartpole
the
essentially if you want to get the first
observation you just do an m dot reset
that also resets the environment
the observation is just going to be a
vector of values in our case it could
also be
i think a matrix of values but in in the
case of cartpole it is a vector
and uh we do print them out here so i'll
explain those in a second
uh then basically we loop the
environment so while it's not done just
keep going give us the reward
let us know if the environment is done
for whatever reason
i believe with cartpole the limit is
200 frames and the reward
is i believe each frame that you stay
alive so the idea of cart pull
is to keep this pull
balanced on the cart so you have to move
the cart to keep the pole balanced
so then let's see the observation this
is going to be that vector we talked
about
so this this is any environment
information that you have so this is
going to in theory be the input
to the neural network and we want the
output to be
uh whatever action that we want to take
now again the documentation on these
environments isn't the greatest
um so with cart pull for example the
sometimes it tells you yeah so at least
in this case we know we want to apply a
force
in the range of plus one actually not
even in the range it's either a plus one
or a minus one
and that just moves the cart left or
right then we have
um
[Music]
yeah so so in this case the reward is
plus one but it's not actually telling
us what the uh
what the observation is so in the in
this case
well one it doesn't really matter but
but um i will explain it in a second so
let's go ahead
and oh actually i want to run this from
here
and we'll just say python 3 i think
3.8 uh m testing
okay so in this case we have um
this is our observation that initial
observation that we made right so i
print the observation and then we
also print the action space so that's
what that discrete value is
give me the um
okay so so this is the observation i
believe
it's something like
cart um maybe cart position
cart velocity
pull angle i think
and then like pull velocity from the tip
i think
i think that's what those values are but
again it's not really that important
um they're just useful values so
so that's the environment i'm pretty
sure that's what those are but yeah and
then the action space this just lets us
know like hey what
what what are the options here it's
discrete so it's going to be either
negative one
or positive one that tells us that and
in fact
actually this just says one and zero so
well this is v1 maybe that's the
difference i'm curious let's find out
let's see if v1 is actually different uh
let's try that one more time
it doesn't look like it so
uh just just to put this to so you
understand what we're looking at zeros
and ones
where as we run this observation we're
just taking
so with open ai you can just say
m.actionspace.sample
and get like a sample action so it's
just the if in effect we're just
doing random actions um so clearly
actually
actually the action is a zero or a one
okay sure
okay so um yeah so so that is the
environment that we're going to be
using now coming back over uh
here uh what we're going to do first is
go back to neat python we'll go to the
github page
and we are going to apply this
to
we'll go to their examples they do have
a cart pull example i want to say
single pole balancing hello
and um and yeah they actually have a
bunch of different so they
they've written their own version of
cart pull what good for them
um but we're going to use the open ai
one just
for simplicity so when we go to change
the environment you it's more clear what
changes
um so there's two things we have the
uh evolve so we're gonna use the feed
forward version of evolve
and then we also need the configuration
file so we're going to say config feed
forward
so we'll come over here and i think what
i'm going to do
is just copy and paste this entire thing
we don't need to import the print
function from the future because we're
using python 3.
uh now let's see
i am not going to import visualize i'm
not going to bar um you can check that
out later that basically just visualizes
your
model so i'm going to also delete that
and i'm actually going to delete that
cool
yes okay so um so here's the thing that
like this is why i kind of wish um
there needs to be like some sort of api
because like all of this code
is not going to change it's all you all
i really arguably this
is never going to change this is never
going to change
now i could be wrong but in all of the
things that i used the neat algorithm
for to play with it
i never changed any of this code to
train
and then arguably the eval genome this
is
the thing that you're going to change
this is where you are going to be
running
your actual uh environment getting
rewards
um and notifying the um
this this this algorithm um
how good the simulation went so this
will change
but even this could be much better i'm
highly tempted to
to make something that sits on top of
this package
but anyway let's go ahead and
basically add our environment so again
their environment
is essentially here
yeah um so what we're going to say is
rather than sim so actually i'm just
going to kind of pop this over
maybe here uh what we're going to do is
we need to
import gym we define our environment
like so uh then
runs per net we don't need to have a
bunch of runs per net
um i'm going to say i guess two
is this this depends this is going to
depend on how does your environment
start is it like a really random
initialization
if it is you might want to give your the
network
a chance to have a statistically
relevant
um number of runs before you you know
kill it off so to speak
so keep that in mind uh we'll leave it
at two that's totally fine simulation
seconds
uh is not relevant because this this
environment will kill itself on its own
uh so basically this here so this
rather than this becomes wow not done
um fitness equals zero we'll say
done equals false here the
sim this is where we're going to replace
with the
um
because we're multi i think yeah i think
you'd want to put this in here because
this is going to be
sent out to many processes and you
wouldn't want to share the environment
so yeah so we'll throw in the
environment there
while not done this is where we
um i want to leave
net activate that becomes your action
inputs okay so there we go
so as we kind of butcher this i just
want to show like how to apply your own
problem essentially so
so while all we're trying to do is get
the fitness at the end of the day
we're saying okay for however many runs
that we want to run
you know this network on here's the
environment
here's our starting fitness let's
actually run a trial here
and then we're going to append that
fitness since we might have multiple
runs
to overall fitness and then we return
min mean max whatever you want so in
this case
they're suggesting we return the minimum
i'm going to say
actually let's go with np.mean so
numpy.mean
so we'll go ahead and import numpy
import numpy as np
um cool so let's continue
our copy and paste of our environment so
while not done that's essential we're
essentially here
what we're going to do is m.render we
don't want to render it
we'll do this observation oh we need to
grab that
very first observation as well action
input net dot activate inputs we'll say
action
so rather than taking this uh random
action we'll take the action that the
net
uh this so net activate is kind of like
net. or you know model.predict let's say
if you're
used to deep learning um and we need
that very first is
m.reset yeah so we need that very first
observation so observation equals m
reset
we need to figure out what is our action
that we're going to take we're going to
take some action based on some
observation we get that action we take
that action boom we've got a new
observation
and we have a beautiful loop we also
have reward so
now we're going to say is fitness um
how do we want to do this this is going
to be per frame something tells me their
fitness
might be calculated differently we're
going to say fitnesses
fitness in this case fitness needs to be
plus
equals plus equals so we've got
fitnesses this is
total for the each kind of run
and then we need to kind of um in this
case it's how many frames
did we stay alive essentially but we'll
we'll pass reward
it could also just be plus equals one
but we'll we'll throw in the reward just
to keep it
um in line with you all the possible
environments that we might run
so i think we're good
now we just need the config file so uh
yeah so why not done action
fitness and then fitness is we append
this overall fitness score to here and
then we return the mean
again we're only doing this in case we
ran many runs i
i can't remember with carpool i think
carpool might initially
initialize in the center but then the
pole might be in a kind of random
position
i i forget
okay i think we're ready uh other than
we now need the config file
so the config file again is a thing that
i think could be severely cleaned up
so uh here config feed forward cool
beautiful
uh let's go into here and we already
have the i guess i've just
left it in here so i'll explain it um
let's open it up
okay so in this case we're saying so
fitness threshold again there's kind of
two things here so this is going to
return the mean but then
each genome has a population that has
like different
traits i guess so in this case
this is all about this very specific run
example
what is the fitness we want to return
and then in this case
this is um
[Music]
for like the group i think so max but
i'm
going to go with mean again
there's a case to be made for men as
well
not important um again this is one of
those settings that like
for me i have not really found like
again either the problem gets solved
pretty easily
or it just simply doesn't and maybe
again it might be because i'm an idiot
and i don't really know exactly how all
this is working
so please do feel free to tinker i'm
just telling you what i have personally
found
thus far so uh fitness threshold so this
is basically going to be like okay at
what point
based on this is it going to be so if
the average of that genome
is um 75 or above
hey we're successful we're done and then
all we'll do from that point is uh
return
um basically who is the best
so and then we'll dump that model and
then we can use that model
so in this case we actually need to be
200 200 is
you stayed alive for 200 frames it's a
simple problem we should be able to stay
alive for 200 frames
so we will leave that now um
i'm going to come back to this but i
just want to point out
like basically this all the way down
really i think all of these again these
are things that
you have to have them here but they
don't
actually need to be here this should
just be something you can tweak if you
want but
this could be so much simpler in fact
you don't you shouldn't even have a
config file i i feel like
this could be a function call really
simply um
yeah anyway but this is what we have so
num inputs coming back here
this is basically the things that you're
going to need to tweak is going to
be depending on your out uh your
environment to be fitness threshold
um population size this is essentially
how many of these processes are going to
run at the same time
so this is going to depend heavily on
how many cores
does your cpu have and how challenging
and how heavy is your model so carpool
very lightweight model
so i i could probably set this to i
don't know 500 and be totally fine
if you're on like a little two-core
laptop um maybe don't do 500 maybe do 50
or 100 or
you know figure out what what your
number is but um
yeah so cool got that
okay num inputs so this is our this is
essentially our neural network
so what our num inputs would be is what
is the
shape of our um
[Music]
our observation in in our case we're
calling it observation
well remember that was four unique
values so
our input is gonna be four number of
hidden
again this is going to depend heavily on
what kind of
machine you're running on i think
carpool could actually be solved
ah this is tough i i don't know if it
could be solved i'm gonna keep this at
two for now and then if i remember to
we'll set it to zero just to see
i think carpool could be solved with
zero hidden layers
and then num outputs so again in our
case this outputs either
a um
a zero or a one is what we want
and we can see here the activation
function that's going to be used
is clamped you can also you have a
default and then you can also have
different ones i believe they're just
separated by space they have a whole
bunch of activation functions so we can
come back here
i guess i didn't uh neat
okay we'll just search it again neat
python
and let's do activation functions
clamped might be new to some of you guys
um cool
why is it all i don't like that anyway
here's the clamped
so clamped goes from negative one to
positive one we could also do
um i don't know you could do hat
in this case it could be pretty simple
rectified linear would be an option
so our number of out
i it just kind of it's up to you so we
could actually have one
um one at the output and then
is it a zero or a one um or we could
have two and then run an arg max
so i'll put it at two and we can just
run argmax on it
and we'll keep clamped i actually find
clamped works really well
again um i've tinkered so much with his
activation functions
um i like clamped clamp seems to be
really great
so i'm going to go ahead and save that
and we'll come back over here and
actually our action is going to be
np.argmax of the observation so again
the output is going to be two values
we're just going to say hey
it's either a zero or a one because
again that was our action choices action
zero action one so
that should work so coming back over uh
to our config file
some of the other things that you might
really have an urge to tweak as i did
was these bias min and max i really
felt like hey that should be uh negative
one and one
and same thing with the um
this range here in the 30s and then i
want to say weights are also i don't see
weights on
in here oh here it is blind
i tried putting those to negative one to
one and uh that didn't do better
so again like these are all really great
defaults i would just leave them
i would really just start with this and
um
yeah try that out so okay so let's go
ahead and run it
save that this is neat uh okay let's run
it
and see what kind of errors that we see
python 3.8
this is neat.pi in valid
syntax that was not one i expected today
but
it is what it is okay it's striking
no oh
so we're still trying to import the
original cart pull and we are
not using that we're using jim wow
we haven't made it past the imports yet
config
feed forward oh we called ours config
they call theirs config feed forward so
again you might have different config
file names
um there we go uh
this will save it as winner feed forward
let's go ahead and just call it winner
and anything else
how many more errors
this is interesting we are hitting best
fitness of 500.
i thought the max was 200 maybe carp are
we doing carpool v1 now
maybe carpool v1 can go to 500 but i'm
also curious why
um so we hit the fitness threshold but
we had 500
oh this is the average fitness and did
we say we want it i think we did say
that didn't we
uh fitness threshold was 200 and it was
a mean
so okay everything is working how it's
supposed to work and i'm just dummy
um yeah okay interesting okay so the
average here was actually 163 and so
yeah we it just took a while to work up
to that but
by a while as you can see what i mean is
like a minute
so so cool okay so so now
it works we think we got a good score
how do we use it so again
um i find the application
of these things to be challenging but
um and this could also be very like way
simplified in my opinion oh i've got it
up already
uh so test neat so again
um
this will never change this is always
going to be the same you need to load in
the genome this not gonna change the
only thing that might change is the name
of the file but we already changed it
to config again
um this doesn't change if it's not a
feed forward network that might change
but my point is
this is all like boilerplate code that
we keep having to repeat and it's kind
of silly
we are not using carpool v0 we're using
carpool v1
and i think that actually is important
because i'm pretty sure carpool v0 maxes
out at 200 or maybe 200 is the solved
state i don't know okay
so we make our observation while not
done
what action do we want to take um i'm
not sure what this comment is for
i have no idea i'm gonna get rid of it
um i might maybe it's for a different
i don't know oh i think it's maybe for
the bipedal
no i don't know i don't know anyway get
rid of it
um in this case we want it to be
mp.rgmax
of net activate observation
and then we step and then we render
so let's go ahead and test it again i'll
put all the i'll put links to all this
that way
because again i there's like no reason
to write this out
like it's always going to be the same um
but okay
so uh python 3.8
uh test meet
okay as we can see we are balancing
the heck out of that pole
okay looks good no surprise there um it
must be 500 frames as the max because we
were still
still very successfully balancing this
pole
as a darn good pole balancer so
if you wanted to do this with like
reinforcement learning
it would it would take you longer like
traditional deep
reinforcement learning it would take you
much longer
than like 30 seconds or whatever it took
for us
to solve this problem so that's one of
the cool things is it's like
it's such a lightweight and
relatively intelligent way to like
search um
search for the i don't know the answer
to a problem now
the problem with the neat algorithm is
you're really only going to solve
simpler
types of tasks so again it's it's task
like i could solve it with neat much
quicker than i could write a program to
do it but i could write a program to
also balance
the pull right but i can use neat
to do it much quicker and it does a good
job of it
so so now let's go ahead and um
let's apply this to that bipedal walker
so again
coming over to neat or
closed ai here we're going to go to
environments
and we're going to do this bipedal
walker
oh this one he has to walk over stuff
we're going to keep it simple but go
feel free
or maybe apply it to the lunar lander
try something else
but i'm going to start with the bipedal
walker so coming back
to i guess i closed
i closed the other page
here we go uh environment testing open
up
okay so we're going to do
a bipedal walker
v two
so i'm gonna copy that name i'm gonna
pasta that name
and again this script doesn't need to
change because we'll see
what is our action space what's our
observation and so on so
let's go ahead and run
okay
so python 3.8 uh m
testing yeah
okay so they just they've been so busy
being open they haven't updated their
website i guess
so it's actually uh there is no v2
available
it is only v3
oh i have it
i had it the whole time already ready to
go
didn't have to make that mistake i wrote
i did this like a while ago i've been
i've been sitting on the neat algorithm
for a minute uh
m testing boom okay cool not well
that random was not that bad okay let's
go to tippity top here
okay so recall this
is our
what i find this to be
not useful this is a
box what is a box i don't know what that
means but anyway
whatever so this is our observation this
is
um i guess it's a matrix but
we'll flatten it out it doesn't have to
be so
uh
actually it's not it is just a vector
it's just properly formatted
anyway we've got what one two three four
by one
two three four five six so 24 values
so so our our input is going to be a 24
and then down here we've got these are
each
of the sample actions so i guess based
on this i can
imagine a possible action is anything
from negative one to positive one
and we have four of them okay
uh great so uh again
coming back to here
uh let's check clamped again and just
i'm pretty sure clamped is negative one
to positive one
it is so boom we can use clamped again
you
you can feel free to use some sort of
sigmoidy type thing or any of these
other ones that you want
just make sure it can actually do the
range right so in this case if you
started with sigmoid
um you'd have a problem right
because you would never activate to the
negative that we need
so just keep that in mind but you can
use imagine sign
what a crazy activation function but you
can use it if you want
okay so um
okay so so we have our bipedal walker
what needs to change we know input
is uh 24 values and we know
i think that's what our config file was
actually left at um
so we know where are we input values is
going to be 24
hidden we can keep it at two i forgot to
run zero hidden someone
just do it if you're curious i guess um
and then num outputs
is going to be four so we'll go ahead
and save that and that's all we're gonna
change we're not gonna change
anything else because we don't have to
um because
you would have to think about are we is
clamped still a viable choice
but in our case we want to range between
negative one and one so
cool that's fine so
coming back over here uh rather than
cart pull
v1 we're gonna change the environment to
be a bipedal walker
so this is our main kind of train script
boom runs per net again i'll just leave
it at two i don't really care
um uh forget i think
i think in this case i think reward
is how far you got
where's given from moving forward
if the robot falls it's a negative 100
so i think again reward will be
cumulative
we'll just continue pulling reward that
might like these are the things that are
going to change right like how reward is
calculated
might change um like you might actually
only have a reward at the very end
so for example um i don't know imagine
you have
i don't hear mountain car is a good one
you only get a reward if you make it to
the flag so anything else that you do
um doesn't give you a reward and
you know simply moving back and forth is
no good so number of frames alive is
irrelevant
so different environments will have
different rewards so anyway just keep
that in mind but in this case i think
they stack just fine
now rather than doing an np.org max on
the output
actually we're going to take our action
based exactly on the output right
because the output ranges
um cool so again we'll do mean that's
totally fine
and then again i'll just remind you that
fitness criterion is mean
200 might be a little a little much
um we'll set that to max and then uh
because i don't want to wait for a mean
of 200 i think that's gonna i don't
think we're gonna get there
um but you've seen what a
random is right like we've shown random
and so essentially
random is this right
this is random so you'll know
if we've learned something um i think
we'll start at
50. i think we'll make it 50.
and then we'll see how that works so
cool whoops oh now i gotta
get this all back
good enough uh okay so let's go ahead
and run that
so python 3.8 this is
neat
i'm not sure what we're seeing all these
for what is this
why
i'm not sure why why
maybe it's the input because we're
taking an action based on
box bound casting to float 32 so i
wonder what
the output is that we're getting okay so
this is actually taking
considerably longer uh
let us i think our population yeah
our population might be a little large
for this one
um
[Music]
that's something i would probably tinker
more with to kind of determine like
is there any reason to have a population
that large
for i think i might shrink the
population just so we can iterate a
little quicker
um was our pops okay we'll set this to
250.
um come back over here how are we doing
at this
oh wait are we did we finish
i don't know if this is the right one
uh we only have two things open
best fitness best fitness was 85
okay so this should work actually okay
great so let's come back to test neat
now
again the only thing that changes here
is okay what is the environment we're
gonna run so we're gonna run by peter
walker
um and then rather than our you know an
np.org max again we're just going to run
the straight output
cool all right let's see how our walker
did
i didn't think we'd get a result um
anytime soon python 3.8
test meet dot pi okay
okay okay
i mean he's making moves
and you saw random this is better than
random
it's pretty good
oh no
okay again i want to stress that
the neat algorithm produces stuff like
this which is
it's neat it's cool uh you could write a
rule-based algorithm that does this
um and solves these environments kind of
like this
but the neat algorithm i would argue for
sure solves that one way quicker than i
could ever
write anything for i don't think the
neat algorithm is going to solve
you know huge hugely complex problems
purely because of the way that it goes
about solving them it's not quite brute
force
but man it's really close to brute force
where
if you have a big search space and the
the only thing that could possibly fit
is a very complex thing it's going to
take you
forever to to find it
so you know in that in that sense i
suppose you might eventually like have a
really complex problem and the neat
algorithm could find the solution
but it might take it would take much
longer than something like
you know deep reinforcement learning um
could so
anyway um that's pretty cool so uh i
encourage you to kind of tinker
with the neat uh algorithm to come up
with um
a unique application um
you can use maybe the open ai
environments or try something out maybe
i don't know tic-tac-toe or something
like that
and see what you can come up with it is
it is truly a neat algorithm i enjoyed
kind of tinkering with it so the
environment that i wanted to try the
neat algorithm on
was conway's game of life if you're not
familiar it's an extremely simple game
with essentially four rules that dictate
cells spawning or dying some versions of
the game have more or less rules
but it's very simple you can look it up
if you want you can even write your own
game of life if you find this
interesting
there's no actual movement but the
result of these births deaths and
stagnations
produce visuals and structures that do
appear
to move what you see here is a random
game with two
and by random i mean initialized
randomly with two uniquely colored cells
in a game of life that i wrote but you
could have just one color or you could
even have many more colors my curiosity
was if
the neat algorithm could actually learn
to build structures that
survive so the way i did this was by
allowing the need algorithm to initially
place up to 10 starting cells obviously
this is
a parameter that you could change then
just see how many frames that this
structure stayed alive
so if it ran off the screen that was a
death and then also
if um if everything just stopped that
was a death and then also
it was a calculation of repeating frames
so initially the question was if any two
frames
so in a range of uh basically three
frames is there any repetition because
there's a lot of like back and forth
movement that winds up happening
so if you don't put any limitation on
repeating frames which you'll get
almost immediately is this kind of like
three cell repetition just flipping back
and forth back and forth and back and
forth so i knew going in there would be
the flipping back and forth of cells so
that was something i thought of in
advance
and just knew would be a problem what i
did not expect was there is actually
a sequence of three frames that will
repeat over and over and the algorithm
actually
relatively quickly learned this one
instead
so then once i stopped that from
happening
the algorithm was actually pretty quick
at learning various structures but it
would always make the exact same
structure
which kind of makes sense so then i
started randomly placing
red cells as well like in the same 10 by
10 window
just to see if we could come up with
some different structures and
it did so then i got curious what if we
let the algorithm place in a 10 by 10
window of a much
larger map what might happen in that
case
so this was actually one of the first
things that it made was one of these
little gliders
and then adding back in the kind of
random red cells just to see what would
happen
and then a much larger map you can see
here that actually just a
handful of cells in this case it was
only six total cells becomes what you
see here
which is pretty cool so it can place up
to 10 but if it attempts to place a cell
in the exact same location then
so be it just doesn't count
so i finally decided it'd be cool to
make one
large play area and let the neat
algorithm place
in essentially four quadrants of a
largest map
to start i allowed to have also the same
kind of random placement of the red
cells
and then just see what happens and this
is the result it seemed to be
quite a fan of that starting placement
u-shape structure in this case
um but there were other shapes i promise
that it came up with like you saw the
glider there was another shape i called
the 176er because it stayed alive for
essentially 176 frames like i kept
seeing that number and i was like what's
this
and there's this really specific
structure that stayed alive for that
long
so anyway pretty cool that's the neat
algorithm with i guess a
cool cherry on top by applying it to
conway's game of life i encourage anyone
interested
to go ahead and tinker with the neat
algorithm and come up with your own
ideas it's actually a really fun
and like i said neat algorithm to play
with aptly named
and pun intended so anyway that's all
for now questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise i will see you all
in the next video
you